who knows who how bad hence judo's fight
was he says his shoulder's really bad he
says it's a 50 tear if you were to go
through Camp things you'd tear it fully
and then you'd probably have to retire
so I get both sides I talked to Cheeto
uh on Sunday about it you know he's like
tap and sucks he's like live and learn
hopefully they find somebody else he
wants Peter yawn yeah I would say
everything what made sense about that
except that Henry said yeah but I'd like
Peter Young or so and so after like you
had that whole statement about this and
that and but then you give us two
opponents that are ranked higher than
Vera which tells me that you didn't want
somebody ranked Rivera was at that's
where he tells his truth is the thing
it's like my shoulder hurts too much
Rivera but if we can get algeman
Sterling or oh Peter yawn my shoulder
doesn't hurt as bad